The joe rogan experience. Whose idea was
this for this show? That was my idea.
Jesus Christ. Dude,
you're an unusual human.
It's fun though. And how many
of these episodes have you done?
We have finished six. And you're going
to that, is that the entire season?
Yeah, that'll be season one comes out in
July. You excited about it? Yeah, I'm,
I'm pumped. So 50% of the time
you almost died. Yeah. Yeah.
I mean that's a gross math
around it around. Okay.
So there's the water one. Well you almost
froze to death. Yup. That definitely.
And then the avalanche one
will you lasted 30 minutes.
What was the other one? Oh Man. Oh Man.
Yeah, of worse. Yeah. I mean it was,
it was, it was less pleasant. Um,
like I was a bull fighter for an episodes
out dude and not a bull rider because
they're insane. But the bull fighter
is the guy that's on the ground.
So when the bull fighter gets thrown,
he's the bodyguard for the bull rider.
His only job is to take the hit.
So the bowl writer doesn't get trampled
to death because the moment the bull
rider comes off the Bulls back,
the bowl is turning around to
crush whatever was on its back.
And that's where the bullfighter runs into
save him. And uh, you know, the, the PBR,
the professional bull riders association,
um,
those guys are the most selfless,
courageous guys trying to protect
those bullfighters um, bull riders.
So I trained for a while and I was,
went to the biggest rodeo in
the nation and was bull fighter.
And um, I mean this isn't one of those
shows where people don't get hurt.
You're like, you see the inside of my
body, you see people get really, really,
really jacked up and go to the hospital
and like he does he have a punctured
lung? Is that guy going to live? Um,
this is that type of show cause there's
no other way to do it. The only thing,
the only direction we had from
discovery was don't fake anything.
That's a great direction.
That's great direction. I'm
glad they came up with that.
Now what happened with
the bowl? Um, well I,
I got owned, which is humiliating
because they're not really smart animals.
You're fast over there.
Jamie's a wizard. Yeah.
I like to encourage all little boys and
girls that follow me on any social media
platform to stay in school,
become engineers, architects,
accountants are anything that doesn't
lead to permanent brain damage or need of
an orthopedic surgeon.
It's you legs up and a bowl
watching you through the air.
That was the training week.
So this was when you were
trying to distract the bowl.
What kind of techniques
do you use? Uh, football,
running back stuff just juke them one
way and the is you actually have to sell
that body movement.
So like your weight,
half your weight has to shift far
enough where the bowl is going to really
believe that you're going
to go to that direction. Um,
I wish bowls were so I wish they are
dumber than they are because they're not,
cause if you fake them once one direction,
they won't take it the next time they'll,
they'll you try to fake to the right.
They'll already start
going running to left.
So then you fake to the right and you go
back to the left and you're like, oh no,
I have done an, it's at that moment that
Tim realized he had fucked up. Yeah.
Then it just gets her own.
I got destroyed.
And so when you get launched through the
air by a bull, it's, it's, it's weird.
Um, because it's, it's
weightless, you know,
it's just a second and you
are completely inverted.
No control over where your body is going
because you didn't generate that energy.
Um,
but the other part of you,
the other part of your brain is knowing
that that bowl is going to try to turn
as fast as it can and get you
when you land on the ground.
Cause that's what it's really
good is when you're down. Yeah.
So you're trying to keep track of
where this bowl is while you're hurling
through the air. Like okay, I got to
Tuck my chin so I don't break my neck.
You know, hopefully I'm not close enough
to the fence. The fence doesn't move.
The fences metal,
the other ground is pretty soft.
I'd rather land on the ground
and then land on the fence.
The fence will mess you up anyways.
So that's anyways.
And how'd you get away from the ball?
I'm an athlete.
I'm not sure if you know
that. That's it. That's it.
Just athleticism. Yeah. Luck. Little luck.
The luck that you didn't get stomped.
No.
So there was some real bull fighters in
the ring with me that I think saved my
life every single time because I suck.
I at the end of this show,
people are going to look
at this and be like, one,
Tim is an idiot to everybody
that does this job.
These jobs has the biggest
balls and our show. Bad Ass.
Hopefully that's what
they're going to get.
Cause this isn't like a Tim Kenny
look cool show. This is, um,
that guy's an idiot and everybody else's,
it's that fucking picture.
Oh my God. Oh my God. Look
at that picture. Notice that.
That's a different bowl. So you
said this more than once. So this,
this bolt is,
he's got his feet up in the air and his
head is inches from you and it's about
to collide with you and there's no fucking
way you got away in their situation.
There's no way that thinks way too close.
What is it like to just
get a launched 2000 pound
fucking meat vehicle?
Okay.